quand je pense aux interactions individuelles que j'ai pu avoir
avec des étudiants qui soutiennent le travail que je réalise
et qui, à la fois, y voient un défi et ne le soutiennent pas.
J'ai découvert que,
s'il peut être difficile de changer les valeurs d'une communauté,
nous avons beaucoup à gagner des interactions individuelles.
Si je n'ai pas pu interagir avec John Derbyshire
du fait de l'annulation de l'invitation,
j'ai pu dîner avec Charles Murray avant son intervention.
Je savais que la conversation serait difficile.
Je ne m'attendais pas à ce qu'elle soit plaisante.
Mais elle a été cordiale et j'ai mieux compris ses arguments.
J'ai découvert que, comme moi,
il croyait en la création d'une société plus juste.
Mais sa compréhension de ce que la justice implique
est très différente de la mienne.
La façon dont il voulait comprendre le problème,
la façon dont il voulait aborder le problème de l'inégalité
divergeait aussi de la mienne.
J'ai découvert que sa compréhension de sujets comme l'aide sociale
et la discrimination positive
était liée et profondément ancrée
dans sa compréhension de diverses croyances libertaires et conservatives,
ce qui diminue et augmente leur présence dans notre société.
S'il a exprimé ses points de vue avec éloquence,
je n'ai pas été convaincu.
Mais j'en suis ressorti avec une meilleure compréhension.
Je crois
que pour réaliser des progrès face à l'adversité,
il nous faut être réellement déterminés
à mieux comprendre l'humanité.
J'aimerais voir un monde avec plus de dirigeants
profondément familiers avec les points de vue
de ceux avec qui ils sont en profond désaccord,
afin de pouvoir comprendre les nuances de tous ceux qu'ils représentent.
Je vois cela comme une démarche continue impliquant un apprentissage permanent
et j'ai confiance dans le fait que je pourrai apporter quelque chose
si je continue à créer de l'empathie et de la compréhension
en interagissant avec des points de vue peu familiers.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)